well for people who are joining this
livestream this is a meeting where we're
talking about functions in Wolfram
language which have been tagged as
experimental and which we are
considering making non-experimental for
our upcoming future energy release so
this will be a collection of different
kinds of things we're looking at today
and let's start off here with curry um I
don't know I I think we are not really
ready to make this non experimental
because I think we have started to see
serious usage of the simple cases of
this but I'm not completely confident
that the more complicated cases are
right what do you have to say Jose in
particular I fully agree with what you
said we have seen users use usage of the
simple cases and I'm not as confident of
the need of the permutation because
that's the general case but yes we can
we can keep this experimental and see
how to proceed to rate them okay fine
let's move on to the next set of items
um so next thing we have is a bunch of
things related to okay so we've got
remote connect remote connection object
and related things so remote connect you
claim that this is ready for primetime
yeah I think it's doing pretty well it
seems pretty stable as far as I can tell
there's a few minor you know bugs here
and there with passwords and caching and
saving so why don't you sing our
authentication string
well it's using I mean because we've got
now this mechanism for authentication
dialog like an authentication dialog
right like this we'll do that right why
is this not using that that is one of
the things that we meant to add this in
this current release so it's not noon
eleven three but we're planning on
making this switch to using
authentication dialog so that's a
different design isn't it it could use
authentication dialog underneath even if
it doesn't no no but the design that's
specified here I see so this is saying
remote connect of username password is
equivalent to blah blah blah but this
authentication dialog as a second
argument here would suggest that you
should be able to say host and then
username password like that and do we
believe that the do we believe that the
the authentication is always yeah I mean
the way that this caching works okay
you're not proposing the experimental
eyes in the caching mechanism that
correct because that ultimately be
stored in a keychain or something right
yeah I think we want to change that
mechanism but I think after we changed
that a lot of the other things like in
general just the general function is
okay but uh remote authorization caching
is a little bit kind of iffy and I think
we'll want to switch to using the
keychain mechanism and I'm not entirely
sure how that'll look yet okay but so
there's a cluster of things here around
remote run remote run works the same way
as remote connect right yep so remote
run in a remote run process I'll do the
same kind of connection to a remote
machine remote run we'll just
run your commands like you would on the
in a terminal and drum over and process
will actually get you more information
back from it mm-hmm this documentation
is not done correctly this should have
had separators between the things which
are about different topics who is
reviewing this documentation for for
these some connectivity things as I
noted this meeting can he comment on
that yeah over here that it looks little
wrong I agree but what is the general
process here well I mean you you get to
review it as well but no I don't example
like I'm not looking at them I'm
specifically not looking at them I'm
looking at the the functionality stuff I
can put there I know how to do it right
yeah um okay
I don't know I'm I'm not wild about the
experimental izing these particular
things because I feel like there's still
you know we don't really have remote
evaluate working yet do we
not quite I don't think we should do
experimental eyes these I don't think
there's a I don't think it's necessary
to do it I don't think we should do it
um I don't mind waiting waiting another
release or something like that right
okay
let's see the other things you have
listed here our system process data and
system processes so system process data
great that's encouraging
what's that not sure is that a 11 for
Farah I don't know it's a proto okay um
that wasn't the thing I thought I was
opening there okay
let's look at it related to date you
need your unicode changes turn 12 yes
it's possible
let's look at it here okay
so are you proposing the expansion eyes
in this process object or the process
object is already do experimental eyes
because it's the same process object as
started by run process is that correct
yep that's correct sir it's started as
the experimental eyes so we've just been
adding bits and pieces to it so if I
look at this for example and I look at
us for properties of this what will I
see it should show you all the
properties a list is cool so if I say
threads is that the count of the number
of threads yes yep it's not the threads
themselves great we don't have any
thread objects or anything like that yet
okay that's nice though on the path
okay so that's a
straighten that's not a file object for
example okay
program
okay okay
why does it say that in seconds
why is that not turning into something
that is more um something in a more and
more reasonable units what the heck is
that the heck is that what isn't that in
with units memory had units why doesn't
the time have units I think the time
needs to have units make sense I think
so okay and then this should be
converted to some unit that is actually
semi readable I mean I don't see why um
[Music]
it could be hours and days or something
like that well least in this display I
think for the output here arguably it
could stay as seconds
if I do let's say if I do real-time here
oh for goodness sake
you
why doesn't unit convert convert it into
some more sensible units here is the
single argument for version of unit
convert converts to SI base units hmm
it's not actually right I mean is that
what it should do is there a way to get
this to convert to sensible units right
now we bandied around the idea of having
a quantity simplifier we have units
simplify but it is as the function name
suggests focused on the unit part and
not on the quote unquote you know
sensible scaled unit and there's really
should have a mechanism for that I mean
even if it's unit convert with automatic
is the second argument or something I
mean we clearly have the technology to
do it yeah Michael do you have any
general thoughts I think I saw you here
but I would say the current one that the
one argument goes to SI base is for
scientific applications definite
advantage yes fine you don't want to end
up in some black hole formulas with
hours and days mixed things no I agree
but sure so and it's also good to have
something where you can immediately do
numerical comparisons um so maybe we
should try
didn't convert with the second argument
of automatic doing doing this this
different thing mm-hmm
yeah I can't think of any other
reasonable meaning for a second argument
of automatic fun let's try doing this
yeah basically what we do in other can
define something sensible so that number
comes leading ones pretty nice wouldn't
be nicer to have this in unit simplify
and perhaps this will need users
specification of the ranges they want
like give me these from this number to
that number so I would prefer to extend
unit simplifying to do this then unit
convert not unreasonable I'm not sure it
it's like normal simplify we have 84
meaning of it and it's but you can
specify a complexity function that you
can say you consider simpler word
selected it's bigger and I think going
say from seconds to days it's not a
simplification
it's a convert well that's a fair point
okay I don't think that's the discussion
for this meeting I think well we can go
ahead and try to get an implementation
in unit convert with an automatic second
argument and then we can discuss the
possible let's say mmm it seems very
complicated to have a you know unit
standardized I don't know what the right
right term is and I don't like having to
have unit convert to comma automaticall
over the place because I think this is
going to be a fairly common operation
okay but anyway the implementation which
i think is a neck issue does not depend
on this discussion I mean it might be
not enough to test just as one sink like
you probably don't want Everly to go to
one of the exotic as I prefixes even if
it makes the things very nice and short
you won't basically a scientific
like that we've all suggested to get rid
of a used officially and replace
everything by pedo medals and bigger
ones but you also want the human ones
that use is still a use and maximal say
megawatts and not bigger and such things
yes right I mean right but we have a lot
of that stuff in wolf novel right now
yes so I mean just doing what wolf NAFA
does the but what I'm saying is they do
you want it human-centric
or do you want it basically abstract
centric well but this is why the
function needs to be parametrized this
is going to be highly contentious
because people are in different things
yes so so that's why I unit convert this
already complicated so so I would prefer
not to complicate it even more so
perhaps we need a fully new function to
the dedicated to this and then it can be
used with without arguments yeah
actually the interesting point on the
live stream which is about the precision
of this that is if we convert this I
mean if I do a unit convert to for
example today's it's rational yeah I
mean do we in fact lose precision in
this we do when we call and we I mean if
we try and preserve the precision across
the conversion operation so the only
time we introduce floating point errors
is when we're working with something
like a physical constant that has a
measured value that has finite precision
and if you have it in Si base like the
measure of physical constants we try to
keep it symbolic right okay hold on the
couple of points here first okay the
first point is for this function is it
actually a good idea to return things
with units I think the answer is yes
does anybody disagree with that
the question is for this display here it
might be useful to show the real time
even if it's not precise in you know
days and hours and so on right the UM
but in this case I'm beginning to think
it would be better since this is what
the system what does the system report
is it reporting I would have thought it
would report it to higher precision
right the clicks in the system are one
sixtieth of a second or something okay
why is it only reporting it as integer
number of seconds here I don't remember
the exact implementation but I think it
only returns either in milliseconds or
microseconds and I think we're a little
bit yeah well that's not milliseconds
that's seconds there right that's very
weird
why is that oh these that these are all
demons let's try and get some which
isn't a demon oh how about the rocket
chat helper um well get the rocket jet
process because that's when you
relaunched okay so that's still in
seconds for some bizarre reason um okay
I don't know that Garret the I don't
remember the exact implementation but I
can go look into it okay
in okay in terms of design seems to me
the only thing we are specifically
objecting to as the lack of units for
those things
but correct anybody want to comment on
nothing else here yeah I think what you
may want for the real time is something
in hours minutes and seconds like a
mixed radix quantity well for what for
the for the output for the I don't think
you want that because for programmatic
use you're gonna want something which
you can easily compare in easily to
other things no look there's a question
of human readability how making it
readable readable yeah right I mean the
issue is how long has this thing been
running I don't know how long that is
that turns out to be 12 days okay so
probably my computer was last rebooted
12 days ago or something I mean I put
something on there on the rocket jet for
you and maybe you can take a look at
that that's what I'm talking about
I know which I I know that the mixed
radix I know what you mean by mixed
radix yes I understand but what's your
point that's the most readable thing to
me that's readable but I'm saying that's
not what we want as the computer as the
output for the property because whoa is
like making you know doing computations
on it for which it's just gonna be a
nuisance to have it in mixed radix but
that might make sense to have display in
the box yeah that's what I'm saying in
the bottom you can display however you
want but and I agree with you that
displaying it as something like this
rather than 1.1 hours is probably better
something we have done in other cases is
to reduce the precision to three digits
in the summary boxes yes so yeah
equivalent with a with a mix radix so
having two for example yeah that makes
sense to me ours only needs or means and
seconds okay but but other than that
what other issues are there here I mean
the name program as the term for I think
we discussed this at some length right
as the term for the the end of the path
is considered okay not true
I think so that's what we talked about
previously
okay all right so and this thing
think is quite nice I don't really see
an objection to that um I think this is
what we designed I think it's been
working fine
have you been using this this particular
thing I've used that a couple times so
recently for example real-time arrow
what greater than what am I gonna say
here greater than a hundred for example
since it doesn't know units great why
did that not work
that seems wrong I mean because that
will be what I would expect to work from
the way implicit entities work right I'm
wondering if it's comparing against but
I doing a little compare which is wrong
okay should look at this this doesn't
seem right within system process data in
real time is with a quantity right so
can compare quantity with just an
integer this is the quantity it wasn't a
quantity with on my machine it's not a
quantity here look
impress us up there Oh
it is in system process data yeah go to
evaluate evaluate system process data
okay
oh wow well that's a that's bizarre so
that looks like just a bug in process
object okay well fine no I agree that
that's not I wouldn't have typed that if
I'd known
still didn't work
okay so Garrett should look into
those are not documented as working
though it probably should do you agree
documented for greater than or yes yes
yes the implicit density mechanism right
I mean so for example if I say threads
here arrow ten or something this should
give me the ones that have exactly ten
threads which there seems to be only one
okay
so I think that's the issue there so a
little more to do on this function but I
think if we've done that we probably can
do experimental eyes it okay so few
small changes and look into this greater
than quantity I think so external
sessions is the next thing we have on
this list so we got start external
session like Python for example
and that will start an external session
and then if we say external sessions we
will see that session object correct yep
I am not totally confident of this stuff
with the find external evaluators and so
on mechanism I don't think we should I
don't think we should do experimental
eyes this until we have external
function working properly okay
I think individually start external
session and external sessions kind of
makes sense but as a whole I think I
agree there's a few things that we could
write I think those are very close I
think those are very likely to be right
but I think we should wait until we
actually know what's happening with non
non interactive languages
okay is there anything else in your
section that is some ready to discuss
doesn't look like it the other things
you're okay so the next item is live
capture so
[Music]
current screen image so if I say current
screen rule one it will it will screen
capture my primary display is that
correct belief so I haven't looked at
current screen image a bit that was one
of the things he and worked on and I
think okay there you go
that's what it looks like
that's cool all right doesn't work if
you do text recognize on that
you
I think it recognizes Oh some of it but
some of those smaller texts they can
have some trouble picking up and is
there any you're not down sampling in
any way here
right so this is the actual bits that
are on my display driver yeah it should
be the full image that's a bit of a mess
so anybody is Charlie or anybody from
that team here nope not that thing okay
I don't have any objection here to
the way that display screen n is
specified is the same as the way that
that Dulles that screen information
works is that correct yeah I think
that's what was mentioned before well
who knows that for sure
eat in wood but should we sit here and
join us for a minute
somebody sofyan conjoin Hyman Johnson
the person who worked oh yeah other Ian
Bhutto no as a matter of fact Ian Howe
Janaki um should we see if he can join
us
anybody able to do that the question for
Raj yes I can do it okay okay um okay
next up here we've got current notebook
image which is an image of the current
notebook display is that correct yep it
should be the same thing except for it's
limited to the notebook okay let's just
try that
and that's different from rasterize of
the notebook object right
so if I were to say rasterize of this
notebook object I would get the whole if
I say rasterize of evaluation notebook
cat
a display of the whole notebook correct
fascinating
exactly inspiring sounds like we need to
okay so that's that's not great
does nobody understand that I think it's
the wrong team of people here to discuss
that in detail
Berek Berek torn-up oh great I mean it
is yeah it is a very tall notebook and
maybe it did the right thing that by
refusing to UM okay so that is the
notebook content area right great so
what if I want the notebook that's
actually weird look at what it did look
at what it did that's a bug because what
it did there is it rasterized a
rear-ended version of this with the in
and out labels removed that what one
really wants
not sure but it probably creates a copy
of the notebook to screenshot it I bet
that's what it does and that means that
those in and outs change well if we can
get in here then he should be able to
address that issue
[Music]
let's see at an interesting point from
version row on the livestream
once-around
exists unit simplify could actually
uhh
[Music]
keep track of unit of of what precision
loss there is well I'm not sure whether
it needs to be
good question what what the whether we
keep track of the precision loss and
simplifying units okay different
different issue but and another point
from flip Phillip series that he claims
that find external evaluators doesn't in
the pre-release version doesn't actually
look in the in the project I build let's
see whether it works there
find external evaluators apparently
doesn't actually work in the pre-release
version let's try it
laughs well that's a that's a distinct
non-working way we know which which
version that you switch to now this is
pre-release external oh yeah yeah I mean
but it is working in eleven three yeah I
think I can talk with look okay okay but
but this but these webdriver things they
will be gone from external values is
that true or not when when they're being
factored off in their own function are
they still gonna be listed and external
evaluators or not I know that will
change okay we're not gonna have these
like triple like webdriver - chrome -
headless no no I understand them but I'm
asking the question is it the case that
when we have the separate functions for
doing webdriver that we will still be
listing them in the external evaluators
list or not
I don't think we should think yeah and
think about that the okay did we manage
to find you in Helsinki he's here
yep hello okay we have a couple of
questions for you um so we're trying to
do sort of final design review on
various functions particularly the
current screen image and we want to know
in current screen image it has a notion
of what is screen number one and so on
front-ends notion of what is screen
number one or primary display or
whatever else and where does that come
up so screen number the primary screen
you never would see it referenced by
numeral so like number one it would just
be I think the only time you'd ever see
it is in some information in the devices
tab okay well let's take a look at that
but what about in the in the don't don't
we have it also in screen information in
the front end okay so in the device yeah
well this green one and screen to does
that ordering is really defined by how
they're enumerated I don't know if we
could actually get like let's say for
like for instance Windows says that this
they showed his screen or in their you
know in their thing I don't know off the
top of my head if you could make that
match wonder why
so but but hold on so in isn't there an
option in the dollar front end if I say
options dollar front end don't isn't
there something called screen so there's
currently as of right now in you can do
current value of screen information in
quotes
it is my intention to deprecate that in
place of something what the heck is that
I have mm that's interesting
robot tools
huh
what does that mean I mean what's the
[Music]
oh oh oh oh that's
it's the option thing yes um the there's
a bug it dates back a very long time
that front end when it writes that out
right smart symbol so that probably just
got written out to some random context
that happens to be at the front of
probably but even like I said but it's a
bug in the front end the front end
actually writes out the symbol screen
area instead of the spring scrubs crazy
yeah it's very old well mix it well yeah
I'm actually playing a deprecated and
replacing it with a different game it's
being all going to be fine that's fine
but but this particular thing this
structure here how does that correspond
to this to this numbering one and two
here and so on
so in that that's probably going by
order so you know because if there's
multiple you know that multiplied was in
the list it's probably just going what's
the first one list okay but fine but but
what about if I wanted to put a window
you know straddling these two screens
isn't there a way to do that what is the
coordinate system and how can but it's
really it's really hard you know because
the coordinate system all of that all
the window placement is done with window
margins which is all you know offsets
from the you know left right top and
bottom of the primary screen and the
coordinate system a positive direction
goes inward and the negative direction
goes outward but even by M would it out
would so like from the right-hand edge
let's say you know your primary monitor
right if you had a value that said you
know windows margins on right hand side
like 20 that means 20 pixels to the left
of the right-hand edge of the primary
monitor it's good for example if I do
this right it's gonna show that right
and if I say can I say dynamic of this
mm-hm
okay so I so dynamic of that and now I
move the window around
yeah so
to that edge well it's probably best to
see that's with absolute options yes so
that way what are those automatics doing
I mean those are the those are the
things that are determined by the by the
size of the window itself oh it's right
right so automatic basically at some
point the front end switches it's like
ooh this window is closer to the look to
the bottom-right edge that it is to the
upper top edge so imma flip margins to
be that you know to use that as the
basis I don't understand we're not
seeing that here this is showing an
absolute number and then automatic in
both cases right
you have odd so it's basically this
window is 549 pixels in air quotes it's
actually point but you know 366 from the
from the left-hand edge 121 down from
the top
yeah right and then if you move the
window down at some point or and over to
the right at some point you'll see the
automatic jumps to the other dimension
but you can see that I'm moving the
window and it's not happening
except it did the first one is now
before on the other side like so the
pursuit you're absolutely right
yeah well that's cool well it's cool
except it makes it really it makes it
it's not trivial to inspect out that I
wanted to spread all certainly areas you
know the reason we've done this so that
when you set up some initial
configuration for your application you
can do that in a way that doesn't depend
on screen size I mean this was invented
right in a decades ago long before
people had ever heard of responsive
design right yes so and also in the
world where you only have one
you know the majority
right but so let me ask two questions
first of all does anybody know how in
the current world of interface switched
how this would relate to that and in
other words what the analog of the our
responsive design approach for that
would be for this question one question
- what is the story with multiple
monitors here and is this just
completely crazy with multiple monitors
um
I don't know the answer to the first one
I have not thought on I haven't talked
about thought about that in a long time
and I haven't even talked about John so
I don't know in in the multiple monitor
world you know i i've toid with this a
little bit but i don't have a really
good answer yet okay it's it's it would
be it would be a fundamentally different
thing you know yeah i don't know if this
could easily be something that we okay
turn old onto window margins i think it
would have to change if you wanted to
make it so you wanted to go this is
always on the right hand most monitor
that doesn't window martins oh yeah will
probably wind up window monitor or
something so screen i yeah i don't know
i don't know right fair enough
so what this is saying is this
coordinate system is based on this
layout of monitors which is the
essentially the mouse coordinate system
right because it's what determines where
my mouse you know what happens if i move
my mouse to the left to the right
etcetera etcetera etcetera so that
defines a coordinate system if i guess
they can yeah that's what we see here
because that's going to negative side of
my secondary monitor right
yeah so the question is whether it's a
little bit of a weird situation isn't it
um
yes it's very weird it also gets harder
once a couple of things get done
[Music]
right okay so the issue that we're
trying to decide is we've got a design
here for a current screen image hmm
which is a fairly straightforward
function except that the specified
rectangle from the image of all current
display screens mm-hmm so you're telling
me if I have something okay so that
coordinate system is the same coordinate
system as what would the heck to the C
also say here oh they do discuss window
margins um so that's the coordinate
system of the window margins
of the you know the mouse navigable
screen area is that correct
they'll be in yes its origin is based on
the upper left-hand corner so as you
know actually what it says in the this
is crazy
okay look at what this says according to
measure from the bottom left with a
complete area of all current display
screens that's different from the
coordinate system being used by window
margins
right that's actually that's very
interesting
well that's a very interesting spec to
say because that's basically what that's
saying is is it's gonna treat all your
mod all the monitors the the geometry of
the monitor has basically one gigantic
correctly since I know it could be
completely totally off screen that would
be really weird
what do you mean so if I were to take
for example a let's say I say here I say
zero well X min Y min zero zero let's
say 20 20
okay then the question is what
where the heck is that that that looks
distinctly like that corner up there
make it 200 200
or something significantly better with
more
yeah that's that top corner that's that
corner of this window you you can't
probably see the green outline because
that's part of the live stream do male
mate yeah but um okay so what this says
is actually wrong it's actually complete
nonsense the coordinates are measured
from the Y men in this case is at the
top left
it's complete nonsense
okay
system information the list of all
display screens is devices screen
information okay well this is
inconsistent so there's a problem here
and why doesn't this auto complete it's
another problem and somebody should
report for same reason it I mentor I
meant um
whose whose do
in here
do we have a PM or as Raj supposed to be
covering that
alright are you taking notes if there's
nobody dared and I uh you know it's
recorded so we'll we'll go over it make
sure I realized in the Hollyoaks name
that certain care of so bit rash you
should you did okay so that was just not
a complete problem
okay so there's an inconsistency here
this looks like a bug we should we
should resolve it otherwise
apart from this issue I I can set a
current screen image good to go for the
experimental ization but this needs to
be unscrambled so what the coordinate
system should be fix that in the
documentation and then I know fix it in
what it's supposed to do because I'm not
sure what it's supposed to do and you
need to agree with E and what it's
supposed to do okay I just need to agree
that the coordinate system is whatever
this coordinate system is should agree
with what this coordinate system is and
I'm really surprised they don't make
sense
make sense okay current notebook image
they're looking at that
seems to be much less controversial
except that it is incompatible with the
way that rasterize is working on a
notebook object so Ian were you aware
that rasterize on a notebook object is
kind of I mean like for example if I try
and do it for this notebook object it's
just going to say it requires too much
memory
doesn't apply too much it well it
surprised me that it says it requires
too much memory for that but of course I
guess I don't see what everything that's
there well it's a big long note with the
issue so the interesting bit about that
is that you know a lot I'm not going to
say hard values because they changed but
there are platform dependencies on how
big we can allocate surface that we can
render so this is actually not memory
available this is some kind of screen
buffer yeah well I mean in the end it's
for us it's still it's still like a
memory buffer it's just it's a memory
buffer they storing it wait no no no but
this is not it's like somebody's if I
have if I buy more you know Ram Formica
it would fit right then that's not the
case
yeah it's not the case so this message
is kind of wrong right I mean this is
what are you doing you're rendering it
off off off screen display buffer or
something yeah
yeah because I mean you've effectively
asked I need an image of the entire
contents of that notebook
[Music]
which is not the same as I'm asking for
an image of what I can see no no I
understand that what I can see is what
the current notebook image does and
that's working fine but this is not
working which is a separate issue and
I'm trying to understand what that is
and first of all the message is crazy
because it should say something like you
know allocated screen buffer is not
large enough to resin right or something
mm-hmm right so that would be a thing to
communicate to shadi
and her folks um but more than more to
the point why is it that you can't do
this I mean you can't do it in sections
or what could we tile it um do we care I
mean is this something that people are
going to I'm surprised this doesn't come
up in the cloud system I mean what does
the cloud do what it needs to rasterize
a very tall a piece of a very tall
notebook
do you know I don't now on this may in
fact be a bug inside the cloud that is
not readily seen so can somebody point
that out to yon
I guess that's you since there's no
project yeah I I'm making notes yes um
it's possible that we might be able to
get away with stitching it I mean in the
end you still have to assemble it um
yeah but the assembly is just purely an
image object dissemble II is not a
problematic thing I think well for for
us because all of our images are real I
mean I'm a CBO you know they are system
bitmap objects resources whatever you
want to call that yes we don't we don't
treat them as just you know like it's a
it's a flat list of fights but it was
fun as possible it's worthy of lookin to
see if we can do something about that
okay but I I mean I don't know how
important it is but I think you should
ask the cloud people okay here's the
next issue see this that's the
rasterization here mm-hm and what you
notice is that the in out labels got
redone here yes yes
would you care to comment on that so
this is not the first time I've seen it
I've seen that before fixing it
[Music]
okay so here's a so in in for instance I
mean what happens under the hood under
the hood you know when you do rasterize
of that under the hood it is gonna pick
it up and move it someplace else so it
completely and the act of picking it up
and moving it someplace else
triggers the input and output labels to
think that they're no longer associated
it's like a copy-paste then right you
are let's try like that that's what's
going on to make it so it doesn't do
that yeah we can do it but that's why it
does it because it thinks that it's no
longer associated no I'm aware of why it
does it but I mean that's actually
something which presumably would want to
be an option for asteroids because it
depends what you're using the
restoration for sure sure
um
okay but but clearly this rasterization
is something very different
is also totally bizarre because it's
like why does it have certain window
elements and not other window elements
why does it not have the left margin of
the window but it does have the
scrollbar
to me it looks like it's losing a few
pixels on just the margin of the window
like all the way around I think it's
just keeping the scrollbar from that
yeah I mean seeing that that's from what
I know of how that you know things could
be changed since the last time I looked
at this but you know if it's going based
off of I have these coordinates you know
it would have no idea if you know Mac in
this instance added you know a drop
shadow of you know like pixels laughs
you know only only only the window
manager would know that those are there
so depending on how they set that up I
can see that being propped off a little
prematurely
windows I can see that happening on
windows really easily because windows
metrics for the actual outer like the
outermost frame like the colored part
the you know what it reports and what it
actually draws that isn't necessarily a
one-to-one correlation because they're
trying to do that for compatibility
reasons okay
so bottom line is that's kind of a mess
around this by the way it was pointed
out on the live stream that the last
example here well it's not clear it's
wrong it's it's it is doing what the
documentation says it should do but it
doesn't appear to be what it actually
does so there's something goofed up with
a coordinate system okay with respect to
this what you're basically saying is
it's a big complicated mess what window
elements can actually get displayed and
how far out it goes it we can make
educated guesses but you know I mean you
can only be as accurate as the thing as
the numbers that we get and I know on
Windows that that is not always 100% hmm
okay so you you can make educated
guesses you can look up to see what the
metrics are for you know the frame
thickness and you know all of that other
fun jazz
but it won't be bullet
there was no look I don't think we care
right now any pixels that lay lie
outside displayer is because the color
specified by background okay so if I say
this and then I say background arrow red
what am I seeing here I'm not seeing
anything yeah that's interesting I
wonder if the idea is is that if they
blow the wind yeah it was awesome
partially off-screen and then fill the
rest with a certain color yeah right so
I'm going to try that here
I said what it may
oh no that just cropped through it
enjoyed not only did it crop it also
included the green overlay yeah yeah cuz
that's done that's done a lot of times
you know because you can only gain
access to the bits that the window
manager the depositor is actually using
that's visible okay so this is very
confused this background option doesn't
appear to be doing anything or is it the
case that if I were to put I don't know
that I can even do this but if I would
put that window in front there actually
let me let me bring up a palette which
will live in front
um yeah um let's bring up the special
characters palettes let's just stick
that right in the middle there and now
let's recapture oh great huh yeah this
is pretty confused okay this requires
further investigation guys
sorry Garrett I think that's for you
yep that's okay I think okay I thought
it was in a pretty good state but it
looks like there's a couple things we
can look into but but they're not too
bad and I would expect there's a decent
chance that it's going to make it out of
experimental for version 12 okay I think
that's what we needed the end for
actually if Ian could just stick around
just for a moment here
you are recommending
okay so you're recommending not do you
experimental izing Network packet
capture why is that what what is the
story with network packet capture and
whether oh this was totally wrong
because we're gonna rename that one
that's never 8-bit trace so a lot of
those are in somewhat decent state other
than the renamed network packet capture
has their redesign for the interface and
what the heck is this this is a hundred
fifty percent magnification and this
thing looks terrible that looks like a
bitmap an oversized bitmap that
shouldn't be a bitmap it should be a
vector thing right that's very the whole
thing's getting replaced the in the
prototype build I added it but I haven't
tested it yet so it could be
that woke packet capture well as some
some weirdness there oh um but let's try
this so what what he's saying this is oh
my gosh well that looks horrified ah
okay yeah that's definitely so prototype
but okay all right fine all right well
so that's not ready for primetime pcap
okay I don't think there's anything else
for you in here then I thought there
might be in terms of talking about that
interface but that's not thank you in
okay thank you see ya I the um okay pcap
so you claim this is good to go I think
that's just an import of a file type so
that's not as dependent on permissions
as the other functions are so I think
like so the issue for these other
functions as the permissioning stuff a
lot of it is right now yeah good
just because unless you do certain
configurations depending on your system
you might have some difficulty capturing
packets and I'd like a chance to just
kind of stream like line that a little
bit more before we use a system install
or something like that or what yeah
one of the ways we might do it is system
install on Windows there's just a driver
that might need to be installed on Linux
and Mac there's some system settings and
we might have like a pop-up box or
something like that that can let you
agree to it but none of that's you know
I don't think you should be experimental
eyes any of the stuff I think this is
all kind of complicated Wild West stuff
I don't even know I mean this network
interfaces thing okay my machine is a
fairly simple machine I have no idea
what this looks like on some kind of
multi well but and how do these
networking okay
I'm not confident of this but the socket
stuff however better be the experimental
eyes herbal I mean that's been out and
about for ages hasn't it yeah
all of that and why is it still
experimental it to me um it imagine is
because it was new before I don't know
specifically in the zmq functionality is
near WebSockets so that's that's
relatively new oh yeah and what about
this thing with record separators and so
on
I haven't looked at the stuff in great
detail
who has our note have you looked at this
in great detail I did look at it when we
were first designing it but I have not
looked at it again I have used it have
not reviewed it I mean I it is all
working for me or at least you know when
I followed the examples in the
documentation you know it's in the
workable state
yeah okay is anybody else - RIA have a
relation my friend what's that
I've not gone through its function by
function like isn't like a QA testing
situation
for TCP sockets the function is applied
to every data buffer generated by the OS
oh boy okay Garrett can you explain what
this thing is doing so socket listener
sets up a listener and it gives you the
option to set up a function for when it
gets a packet so that's just explaining
for TCP sockets every time it gets you
know a buffer of data that function sees
it and how is that what's the analog of
that for in device read in device read
it yes
no it's device read is also getting
buffers of data and doing something with
it but I don't think it has this idea of
a function that's automatically applied
to the data I don't think it has a
listener set up either for device read I
don't know if there is a direct analog
yet okay what is the relationship
between this stuff on web hooks and
triggered tasks any idea who knows what
the relationship between sockets and web
hooks is
I'd say deafening silence maybe we have
the wrong set of people here
the
oh boy you know these these things being
digs brutalized I'm I don't know I don't
feel completely confident about this
socket stuff especially not in a world
where we're about to okay what's the
relationship between this stuff and
things like URLs submit
I mean URL submit would submit the
request then kind of wait for it a
synchronously right I don't know the
exact mechanism that it's doing the kind
of asynchronous wait I imagined listener
is setting up either some kind of
internal machine setting so I kind of
listener wait or it's doing some kind of
thread I don't know specifically but it
would be nice to know between look we've
we've got multiple things that we've got
channel listen we've got socket listen
we've got and we've got things like URL
submit
um I mean we designed all these things a
while ago I'm just a little bit
concerned about the relationship between
them
because this has handler functions okay
who knows about this stuff is that Fahim
is it Igor anybody know Raj do you know
who these functions are assigned to well
Channel listen would be gore and Ural
submit would be for him okay but and
this function is Garrett is that right
great yes I mean he took over but there
hasn't been much development since I
took over so hey who did this originally
Ian Johnson did a lot of these year I'm
Q no but that's the zero I'm Cooper what
about the TCP part who did the death may
have been dave lebryk okay not sure some
but I think that that's
but the z --m q no I know he was a
little bit more useful for his lesson
produced in 11 to
times that socket listen was all
introduced in 11 - I think that's
correct that that's because that came
with the Zima Qi functionality but so
there were other socket front pieces of
socket functionality that I think there
was one there was one direction I could
suck it open or something for there's
one one socket function that's all
they're not sure exactly which one bit
well all of these are listing 11 - well
one of them probably isn't so let me see
if I can find one
I think socket open was existed prior to
that
does 11 - yeah
I think so I could open was documented
in 11 - it occurred connect was
introduced in 10 3 and was updated in 11
- what's it something like do before we
had socket open well that you see the
examples I mean that's basically like
you know connecting to a socket remotely
and then just you know right this is the
races the simplest form right so this is
the two line web server type deal
is that right no like client right is a
client like you're connecting to a
server oh I see this is the the so this
is saying I see there's port 80 that's
on HTTP its port 80 so now it's why is
it oh it's it's writing so this is the
the two line web client so this is
taking connect to that socket right a
get request and read the result back and
there is coming back as sometime HTTP
response
okay this is not tagged as experimental
this is a complicated mess why is
socket object is not experimental either
so only socket listen which is the
asynchronous listener is experimental
and it's friends correct
why is a socket object doesn't prefer to
socket listen I don't know
well I think these are probably going to
be okay too to experimental is although
I would really like to understand the
relationship how about you get a little
bit more information about the
relationship to these other things
okay I'll set up that meeting okay all
right I see lost my list here is four
for this current iteration is entity
store I think it'd be crazy to the
experimental eyes that right now in the
middle of the database integration
project
I mean is there any pressing need I mean
also I assume we've got um entity
register
is supposed to be and we're just not
ready to do this well it's still tied up
with you know some of the detailed
options are still tied up with the
database integration project so I don't
think there's a thing to do that
all right Raj give us a sense of what
we've got um we're not doing this is
actually disappointingly small fraction
that weird experimental icing can you
give me a sense of what other big chunks
there are well I scheduled machine
learning and system modular stuff for
next meeting because they are two big
chunks and I didn't think we would fit
in this meeting so that's in the story
learning stuff are you is it is it like
hundreds of neuron that layers and
things like this
no I mean I distinguish between neural
nets and machine learning so I'm still
waiting on neural network updates from
tally so machine learning is you know
classify predict that that section right
and in particular things like active
classified which are fairly ornate
designs that I don't think have been
sufficiently battle-tested
right so for example what I have for for
next next meeting is for machine
learning is feature space block 3d find
textual answer that one is going to go
straight through yeah go ahead
yeah preserve color active
classification and active classification
object active friction and active
prediction object feature nearest
feature space plot sequence predict
predictive function then you know
dimension reduce oh yeah okay so there
are plenty of these that are going to be
the experimental eyes that's good I
think the ones that are going to be more
complicated or things like active
classification right and likewise for
system modular we have system model
analytics design you know the create
system model you know system modeling
only a minority of those things is kind
of going to make it I think there's all
kinds of stuff there that isn't ready
right what's the focus of the what
happened to the the system model browser
thing and the and the unification of all
such repository and so on browsers
anybody know
you don't know oh no no no I don't okay
so that was supposed to be some meeting
that is about unification of of in
notebook browsers I think that would be
for Eric to go chase all right anything
else for this meeting
nope okay well thanks for focusing on
the live stream lots of useful comments
and until the next time I'm a little
disappointed that we're you know I had
hoped that we will be getting
three-quarters of these d explorer
analyzed but obviously the process we're
going through is you know a iterative
polishing process and that's why we
tagged these things as a parental all
right thanks a lot guys
see you later